and to get there you have to walk
through the brothel yep and then you
have to [__] your way out of it like a
video game Joe ate his way up
I was like Pac-Man dude
[Music]
I thought it'd be cool if we went over
all of the different
um cosmetic surgeries that are the top
procedure in every country oh cool okay
okay let me guess what do you think the
UK gets done the most teeth
teeth really is that considered
Cosmetics what if it's cosmetic yeah
that's not that's cosmetic what are you
talking about
it's Cosmetics oh nose jobs yeah if you
get like veneers and stuff too oh no I
know his jobs but it's a trick question
it's a true question because their teeth
are [__] up so they don't do it lips
lips thin lips I think it's lit filler
lip filler is the number one because
they get made fun of if they do their
teeth they don't about the lips and
everything else okay so you have like
these big thick lips and these [__] up
teeth but it covers up the teeth though
yeah it's it's a filler does it it just
looks like goldfish to me
what do you think uh the U.S is Boom
tits it was it wasn't 20 it was in 2019
but not anymore what's the bvl bbl's
it's not you get a big butt BBL is
actually not what about what about uh
Botox BBL is like the fifth on the left
oh [__] those jobs how are you good at
this yeah it's a Botox wait what's Botox
again they tighten the face it's counted
as cosmetic procedures yeah like get rid
of wrinkles yeah Botox is like popular
though I feel like in the 90s it was all
nose jobs right yeah rhinoplastic yeah
rhinoplasty now I don't know if anyone's
actually getting nose drugs all right
she's my answer Lasik no you were right
it was putting no I want to change my
answer a lot of dudes get BOTOX too now
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna get I'm gonna
smooth this guy a lot of people get it
everyone gets botoxin
it almost seems like seems like it's
like kind of well-off
what are the things when they poof the
cheeks up what is that fillers that's
crazy that's crazy though because like
you can have complications where it just
like migrates to other parts of your
face yeah like a jowl area I've seen it
I've seen it it's like I'm terrified I
think those dissolve over time though
what do they do but sometimes it's
[__] up yeah what do you think the top
cosmetic surgery is in India India India
India I would say skin lightening yeah
that's what I was gonna guess no it's
not skin lightening
height lengthening surgery uh it's not
height lenting I think that's a very
very few people actually is it wild is
it like feet binding or some [__] no
it's not fee it's not but it's it's not
wild but it is surprising to me I
thought it was I was like whoa I don't
know eyebrow [__] eyebrows is it nose
it's something really basic really like
tea and it sounds like mostly dudes oh
they're not nose jobs uh they they trim
the nipples the areolas [__] muscle
filler Things No it's it's hair
transplants oh there's a lot of ball
Indians I guess what are they
transplanting it to to the Head yeah the
eyebrows just the cheek area no I think
what they do is they take hair from the
back of your head and then implant that
to the front that's what I'm gonna do
yeah my buddy got it done I'm excited it
looks pretty good when are you gonna do
that
when I earn a [__]
hey uh go to Korea Korea is really good
at that and it's a pretty but you're not
gonna do it yeah go to Korea I'll do it
Mexico oh [__] yeah [__] yeah
once I earn the 27 to get it done
best of luck to you
imagine that has a failure rate though
right
nah
don't look don't look into it that's
fine yeah what do you think Mexico's is
Mexico interesting BBL BBL oh that's
good that's actually really good lipo oh
it is they have like the worst obesity
rate and like yeah it caught up to the
US you got the that [__] tortilla
diet man it's tough dude Mexican food is
a heavy [__] if you look at a standard
Mexican Cuisine it's like one serving of
protein and rice beans tortilla carb
carb carbs that's pretty insane yeah
it's like three to one and even the meat
it's like sodium meat carb carb carb
yeah which is also why it's delicious
and for dessert it's fruit with sugar
sugar on top of the fruit yeah it's so
good it's pretty insane because like the
tortilla is like the spoon you use that
yeah
it's so good that's my favorite food
it's delicious even a burrito is the
tortilla with rice and beans on the
inside and then and when you have
leftovers use the chips to scoop it all
up right more carbs and sodium making me
hungry so what do you what do you think
Netherlands is
Netherlands oh Jesus skin darkening caps
I think it's calves Calvin plants you
think everyone's getting calves yup
cabin plans it's definitely not cats
yeah butt stuff it's it's definitely not
butt stuff either damn it is
yeah the tatas it is breast enlargement
we're good Netherlands oh oh because of
the [__] Amsterdam duh what oh all
the hookers are getting there
I don't know if that's the majority of
the population actually non-hookers get
it too yeah majority of the population
in Netherlands are hookers I believe I
didn't know girls needed booby help have
you ever been there yep because I have I
have too I have two what you think well
I didn't eat a hooker out
did you
partake of the red light district
I I window shopped and then I got high
and then I found myself in one because I
was in one yeah yeah you got high and
you found yourself in the morning you
found yourself swiping your credit card
a couple times and then you're in one
yeah I was yeah I would 15 year old you
was like I can't I I can't believe he's
doing this [__] no I was at there was
this marijuana coffee shop it was my
dream come true because there was like a
oh yeah there was like a bulldog thingy
there like and then I went in I was like
you could just smoke wow they were just
smoking joints
that was nice and to get there you have
to walk through the brothel yep
and then you have to [__] your way out
of it like a video game Joe ate his way
out
well I was like Pac-Man dude
Jesus Christ what do you think what do
you think France is doing the most
though nose jobs how'd you know that
attitude adjustments
[Laughter]
no no job they hate jobs no job no job
is really no job no job is better I hate
working they're riding right now dude
yeah there's like a take this it's like
harder than a ride like there's like a
takeover there's like a French
Revolution right now it's crazy yeah
there's like they love revolutions
they're good at it
they love defeating their own country
they just dispatched like 40 000 police
officers restore order or something but
then is it really 40 000 because we know
the little breaks
because French people got [__] up nose
really really I didn't even know that I
didn't know that have you been to France
yeah I've been to France
Jesus Christ Joe can we talk outside
first
what part of the nose is [__] up
nostrils it's not white French people
it's people that move there that wanna
look like a certain way so people that
moved from where Joe where'd they move
from the gypsies how many of them are
there that they would skew the rate to
being the number one surgery these guys
look like [__] Mozart everybody looks
like Mozart
the nose is too big too big what is this
[__]
Oh
you mean like this check these
[__] dude let me see it
for her
I don't know I just got lucky with the
gas
that's pretty cool dude that's a nose
you can't make out with that that's
poking you in the eye you're [__] you
guys never heard of French bigger nose
no it's French bigger nose the male
Figaro
haven't you guys all heard that see now
I don't believe you is this a Saturday
morning cartoon what is this I never
heard of it before
making fun of French people always
protesting and never working like they
never were every country loves to hear
in the French and it's so [__] fun
it's so fun oh my God you think those at
least liked easily out of like the five
eyes countries like the major like
countries I don't think French people
like anybody else but French people too
they got so much pride for no reason
that's really funny yeah dude like they
got wrecked in every war for no reason
and every war they get wrecked bro yeah
it's so true but um they got fire ass
baguettes and that's it we got great
croissants
Spain also has uh nose jobs as number
one Spain which I'm surprised that I
thought Spain people had great news yeah
big noses maybe yes not
let's go Nick or maybe they do because
we're seeing the after yeah let's go
Nick slam though dude what about the the
the Norwegian folks because I feel like
they don't do anything and they're just
beautiful
yeah it says it says None Sweden have
you been there
they're just hot you know why I think
like the Vikings stole all the hottest
girls and brought them back in and they
just have the best genetics dude I was
in Sweden and it was like my sister was
everywhere
good Lord I'm insane never seen anything
like that yeah that's nuts it's so funny
what do you think uh Thailand is
[__] chop off the wee-wee breast
implants
really it's just breast implants because
they're the inverse right well because
they keep it because they like to keep
it some of them keep it you wanna they
wanna create that confusion in Korea is
it the eye surgery
because Korea is pretty hardcore you
know um for a graduation gifts they
usually get plastic surgery wow that's
how common it is yeah Jesus what about
their skin too right excuse me
hey Korean chicks have some heavies
I wonder he's talking about the North
Korean chick yeah yeah no no no wow
everyone knows that now but no Korean
chicks in general I think yeah I think
in Asia as a whole that is the most
common surgery which one which one uh
the eyelid double eyelid because I don't
know what they're doing in Japan because
girls be looking rough out there these
days in Japan yeah man if you're not in
Tokyo everybody else is just like oh man
come on I think it's because they don't
have to compete I'm just kidding I don't
know
what yeah you think of the ratio they
don't have to compete there's actually
more I think there's more females than
males but it's just a lot of guys not
dating so then they they actually have
to compete because there's more females
than males right and then um that means
there's less men dating they have way
more so the girls have to compete they
have to look hotter but they're but
they're not they're failing no I just
made up how ugly they were right they're
actually really pretty so yeah 10 steps
back again so now we are 27 thank you
[Music]